so John people are always talking about
the Constitution but the Constitution
was not the first founding document of
the United States what were the Articles
of Confederation and why did they need
to get replaced
well the Articles of Confederation were
the first loose set of rules to govern
these thirteen states but they were a
mess essentially they allowed the states
to be kind of their own little sovereign
islands so what was it was not a United
Nation it was a it was like an
archipelago of islands and the reason
they were a massive couple of things one
they when they tried to repay the
Revolutionary War soldiers Congress in
Washington with very little power had to
go to the states and say please give us
some money so we can repay the soldiers
a lot of the state said no thank you
we're not going to do that then if you
had a river that rolled through several
different states and you wanted to have
a trade agreement with the Spanish for
example to use that river and trade
along it then the government didn't have
one way to negotiate with the Spanish
individual States had to do it and
individual states had different
interests some wanted to trade with the
Spanish some didn't want to trade at all
and so you had to how do you get those
states to agree on something there was
also not Universal coinage the states
all made their own money and differently
well States might print a bunch of money
in order to pay off some debts and then
the money in one state is worth less
than the money in another who regulates
all of that so Commerce and Industry and
self defense there was no way to raise
an army and pay for it so that the
nation was crumbling before they got to
Philadelphia in 1787 and to your point
in most countries the parts of the
country are called things like provinces
but ours are States because they viewed
themselves as individual countries
absolutely and because of course the
Articles of Confederation had been
formed in the wake of this fear and the
experience of the fear of a monarchy so
they wanted personal liberty and and get
the the monarchy and national control
throw it all away because they believe
that once you consolidate control in the
national of government of any kind that
it would trample liberty and so after
having fought a revolution for the
purposes of liberating the people you're
not going to design a government that
then stomps down on that Liberty so they
created something that
the states lots of flexibility and then
that flexibility allowed everybody to go
off in their different directions so
Articles of Confederation maybe too much
independence for the individual states
so it seems like there was a consensus
to fix it what was the central debate
when they decided to fix it well there
was a there was a consensus it had to be
fixed but when they got to Philadelphia
first of all Rhode Island was invited
and said no thank you so twelve of the
thirteen states showed up and they knew
they wanted to centralize things but
what did that mean and it didn't mean
one president or a Council of presidents
did it mean a strong Congress how strong
could they tell States what to do well
if they did that then they were acting
just like George the third had acted so
they had to iron out all of these issues
to bring enough central control and
enough quick movement of government that
it could address national problems but
not so much that it trampled and stomped
on that Liberty and that was the
constant debate constantly trying to
figure out how to keep the balance
between giving enough national power but
enough Liberty and that some of the
biggest fights included fights over
slavery North versus South fights over
big States versus small States who has
representation in this national
government and how do you figure that
out and then of course the question of
do we want a president will it be a
single person and how the Dickens do we
elect that person which led us to the
electoral college which has had some
bumpy history and where do you think we
ended up if on a scale of zero to ten if
zero was a complete you know independent
states and ten is a federal government
that just controls everything where do
you think the US Constitution ended up
relative to the Articles of
Confederation well in the in September
of 1787 when it gets September 17 1787
when the when the new constitution gets
voted on it is a stronger national
document that has basically three main
parts one the people are at the heart
and center of it it is the people who
are the representatives or at the center
of the republican government the second
thing is that the national government
can tell states what to do in some
instances those instances are
circumscribed but it can happen the
states have to fall in line that was
very new and there is this thing called
a presidency which has created single
person created really in the mold of
George Washington so it is a
nationalized government
but with a strong attention to this
question of protecting Liberty through a
balance of power system so that both the
national government has checks and
balances and also the relationship
between the federal government and the
state government has a number of checks
and balances so even though they went in
a more centralized direction they were
constantly attentive to this idea of
Liberty keeping it free in the states
and not messing with them too much in
their effort to get some kind of
centralized control it sounds like they
might have gone from a one or two with
the Articles of Confederation to maybe a
7-6 well they went I think they went
from from a one or two to maybe a five
or six which has now moved or you know
over time closer to two to maybe an
eight or nine